ein abend in der bar mit ein paar
bierchen könnte so gemütlich sein wäre
da nicht folgendes problem sobald man
ein mal pipi machen war hang an in einem
pilot in dem man alle 15 bis 20 minuten
aufs klo muss deswegen sollte man seinen
ersten toilettengang auch so weit wie
möglich nach hinten verschieben so sagen
es mir zumindest meine alkohol
trinkenden freunde ich bin der sache mal
auf den grund gegangen alles cool bis
man den ersten toilettengang des abends
antritt und zack ist man drin im never
ending pipi dilemma so gibt es bier
trinker regeln wie nie schon nach dem
ersten bier pinkeln gehen sonst ist der
abend ja direkt gelaufen ist das so
liebe alkoholtrinker hier ist was
alkohol mit euren körper bzw
mit euren ihren anstellt unter ihren
produziert ein hormon namens anti
theoretisches hormon kurz hdh und dieses
ada region ihr teile unserer
nierenfunktion unsere nieren sind die
wasserfilter unseres körpers sie filtern
abfallprodukte ab die dann an die blase
weiter geleitet werden wo sie dann durch
den urin ausgeschieden werden
gleichzeitig gegen die nieren auch
nützliche sachen wieder an den körper
zurück darunter auch einige mengen an
wasser die der körper braucht dieses
zurückgeben wird durch das hormon hgh
reguliert alkohol sorgt jetzt dafür dass
kein a dh mehr produziert wird und das
hat zur folge dass jetzt der kompletten
ihren inhalt mit den ganzen wasser das
die nieren sonst an den körper
zurückgehen würden
die blase weitergeleitet wird wo es dann
ausgeschieden trios deswegen ist alkohol
pp auch meistens so klar weil es so
verdünnt ist darüber hinaus mit alkohol
bei manchen menschen irritierend auf die
blase so dass bei ihnen ein gefühl einer
freundin blase entsteht selbst wenn das
nicht der fall ist okay dass man aber in
diesen klo marathon erst mit seinem
ersten wasserlassen hinein gerät ist
reine wahrnehmung sache
es ist zwar schon so dass es ein paar
minuten dauert bis der alkohol das ganze
ada vernichtet hat aber im prinzip
beginnt diese ganze harntreibende serie
in dem moment in dem ihr euer erstes
bier trinkt und ihr kommt doch nur aus
dem dilemma wieder raus in dem ihr
aufhört zu treten damit sich europa dh
wieder nachbilden kann das heißt egal ob
ihr euren herren tragen so lange wie
möglich unterdrückt oder ob ihr aufs klo
geht wann immer ihr euch danach fühlt
dass urin volumen wäre in beiden fällen
dasselbe deswegen nach dem laufen immer
genug wasser trinken weil euer körper
dehydriert ist währenddessen
wassertrinken bringt natürlich nichts
was euch nur noch mehr klo gänge
beschert oder auch mal ein alkoholfreies
bier schön schlau damit wünsche ich euch
einen guten rutsch ins neue jahr gut
dass dieses 2016 bald vorbei ist wir
sehen uns im nächsten jahr feiert schön
und trinkt nicht so viel
eure mama